good morning believe nation today's
message is we are the masters of our
fate over to you Winston Churchill sure
I am that this day now we are the
masters of our fate that the task which
has been set us it's not above our
strength that it's pangs and toils are
not beyond our endurance as long as we
have faith in our course and and
conquerable willpower salvation will not
be denied it I love this message because
it's easy to place blame right it's easy
to blame other people other things you
look at Winston Churchill in England at
the time it's easy to place blame on
their allies for losing the battles they
did it's easy to place blame on other
countries for not joining in the the aid
on the war sooner it's easy to place
blame on all these other parties but
instead Winston Churchill said no this
is on us we are the masters of our own
fate we can control our destiny and when
we accept that responsibility we have
the best shot at beating these guys I
think the same thing is true for
entrepreneurs it's easy for us to place
blame on other people and other things
we blame our family we blame our country
blame our government we blame our
education system we blame all these
other things we blame the economy we
blame all these things that are outside
our control where when you realize that
you are the master of your own fate and
you accept responsibility for your life
you stop placing blame on others that's
when you start seeing significant growth
in your business and in your life so I'd
encourage you to look at all the reasons
why you're not accomplishing your big
goals yet and look at what are the
excuses that you're telling yourself one
of the reasons that you're telling
yourself you're not able to hit this
because of X Y Z what are those reasons
and how much of that is you trying to
just deflect blame on the other thing
instead of accepting responsibility for
yourself so my question today for you
guys today is do you believe do you
fully believe that you are the master of
your own fate and if not what's holding
you back from really embodying that
I'm really curious to find out leave it
in the comments below thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events peso